Sure, back when they were freshmen, Kim and Tiffany and Laura were starstruck when they saw the older kids who took the leads in all the high school plays. There was Sean Bayer, who played Fagin in Oliver. There was Kathy Ferraro, who played Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz and actually hugged Tiffany, who was then just a chorus member, during the big scene when says goodbye to Munchkinland. There was Robin S. Clark, who was just a freshman like them.
当然，当Kim、Tiffany和Laura还是新生的时候，看到那些在高中所有戏剧中担任主角的学长学姐，她们会感到非常崇拜。比如在《雾都孤儿》里饰演费金的Sean Bayer；在《绿野仙踪》里饰演多萝西的Kathy Ferraro，她在那个告别矮人国的重头戏中，竟然拥抱了当时只是合唱团成员的Tiffany；还有和她们同为新生的Robin S. Clark。
Robin S. Clark has been the lead in Cabaret and Singing in the Rain . And when I first met her and I saw her in Cabaret , I was like, oh my god. I can't believe she's a freshman. My god, she's so good. And then I had her in a few of my classes and we got to know each other. And I wouldn't say that we're best friends or anything. But I know her. I had Human Behavior with her. And we were in the same group or whatever, and it was just like, oh, she's in my group. Yeah!
Robin S. Clark曾担任《歌厅》和《雨中曲》的主角。当我第一次见到她并看她在《歌厅》里的表演时，我心想，天哪，我真不敢相信她是个新生，她太棒了。后来我和她上过几门课，我们彼此熟悉起来。我不会说我们是最好的朋友什么的，但我了解她。我和她一起上过《人类行为学》，我们在同一个小组之类的，当时我就想，噢，她在我们组，太好了！
These days, Tiffany, Laura, and Kim are upperclassmen at Oak Park and River Forest High School, just outside Chicago. Now they get the lead roles in the school plays. Now Kim would never be thrown by one girl who she remembers.
如今，Tiffany、Laura和Kim已经是芝加哥郊外橡树园与河森林高中的高年级学生了。现在她们在学校的戏剧中担任主角。现在的Kim绝不会再被某个她记忆中的女孩所动摇。
And oh wow, she was just the lead in 42nd Street and Anything Goes .
噢，天哪，她刚刚在《第42街》和《万事皆空》里担任主角。
Yeah. I really got starstruck with her too. But she was not very nice.
是啊，我当时也特别崇拜她。但她人不是很好。
And I thought she was so cool. And then the times that I'd meet her, she would just totally blow me off like I wasn't even important. And that just really hurt. That just really knocked me down.
我曾经觉得她太酷了。但后来我遇见她的时候，她完全无视我，好像我根本不重要似的。这真的伤透了我的心，让我非常受打击。
But you know, Oak Park and River Forest is a big school. And in reality, most students do not get knocked down if the lead from 42nd Street ices them. Most students at Oak Park couldn't care less. Drama is uncool. Drama is to be ignored. But at Oak Park, as in high schools all across Chicago-land, all across our great Midwest, hundreds of miles within the sound of my voice right now, as I speak to you from Chicago, in every high school there's a small cadre of students, and they're in all the plays. They can discuss at length which show was Melky Boyle's best one. They're the ones who notice the newspaper clipping, taped up in the nurse's office, about Robin S. Clark, who's now in college.
但你知道，橡树园与河森林高中是一所大校。现实中，大多数学生并不会因为《第42街》的主演冷落他们而感到受打击。橡树园的大多数学生根本不在乎。戏剧在他们看来一点也不酷，戏剧是应该被忽视的。但在橡树园，就像芝加哥地区、整个中西部地区的所有高中一样——就在我此时此刻从芝加哥向你们广播的方圆数百英里内——每所高中都有一个小团体，他们参与所有的戏剧。他们可以长篇大论地讨论哪一场戏是Melky Boyle演得最好的。他们是那些会注意到护士办公室里贴着的关于现在上大学的Robin S. Clark剪报的人。
But it said, "Robin S. Clark, the new funny girl."
但上面写着：“Robin S. Clark，新晋的淘气女孩。”
Oh my god.
天哪。
And I was just like, [GASP], I know her. I know her.
我就想，[倒吸一口气]，我认识她，我认识她。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life . I'm Ira Glass back for another week, documenting everyday stories of these United States. Today's show is about the drama bug, people who get it. Act One, David Sedaris tells his mom that he wants to be an actor. Act Two, a month of rehearsals for a real high school play outside Chicago. Act Three, dying for Shakespeare. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，欢迎收听《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass，又一周回归，记录美国各地的日常故事。今天的节目关于“戏剧迷”以及那些被它感染的人。第一幕，David Sedaris告诉他妈妈他想当演员。第二幕，芝加哥郊外一场真正高中戏剧的排练月。第三幕，为莎士比亚而死。请继续收听。
Act One. David Sedaris is the author of Barrel Fever and of many plays, including most recently, One Woman Shoe in New York City. His plays get critical acclaim in the New York Times and elsewhere. He is a Morning Edition commentator. And it was this story of his that he's about to read for us, this story about getting the drama bug, that gave us the idea to do an entire program on the drama bug. We're going to divide up this story into two parts. Here's the first.
第一幕。David Sedaris是《酒桶热》和许多戏剧的作者，包括最近在纽约市上演的《单女鞋》。他的戏剧在《纽约时报》和其他地方都获得了高度评价。他是一位《早间版》的评论员。正是他即将为我们朗读的这个关于成为“戏剧迷”的故事，给了我们做一整期关于戏剧迷节目的灵感。我们将把这个故事分成两部分。这是第一部分。
The man was sent to our school in order to inspire us. And personally speaking, I thought he did an excellent job. After introducing himself in a relaxed and casual manner, he started towards the back of the room, only to be stopped midway by what we came to know as "the invisible wall," that transparent barrier realized only by mimes, drug addicts, and certain varieties of rapid cycling psychotics. I sat enthralled as he righted himself and began investigating the imaginary wall with his open palms, running his hands over the hard, smooth surface in hopes of finding a way out. Moments later he was tugging an invisible rope, then struggling in the face of a violent, fantastic wind.
那个人被派到我们学校来启发我们。就我个人而言，我觉得他做得非常出色。在以一种轻松随意的方式自我介绍后，他开始走向教室后方，却在中途被我们后来称为“隐形墙”的东西拦住了——那是只有哑剧演员、瘾君子和某些患有快速循环性精神病的人才能感知的透明屏障。我着迷地看着他站直身体，开始用张开的双手探索那面虚构的墙壁，抚摸着坚硬光滑的表面，试图找到出路。片刻之后，他在拉一根看不见的绳子，然后在猛烈而奇幻的狂风面前挣扎。
You know you're living in a small town when you can reach the ninth grade without ever having seen a mime. As far as I was concerned, this man was a prophet, a genius, a pioneer in the field of entertainment. And here he was in Raleigh, North Carolina. It was a riot the way he imitated the teacher, turning down the corners of his mouth and rifling through his imaginary purse in search of gum and aspirin. Was this guy funny or what?
当你读到九年级却从未见过哑剧演员时，你就知道你住在一个小镇上了。在我看来，这个人简直是先知、天才、娱乐界的先驱。而他竟然就在北卡罗来纳州的罗利。他模仿老师的方式非常搞笑，把嘴角撇下，在虚构的钱包里翻找口香糖和阿司匹林。这家伙简直太逗了。
I went home and demonstrated the invisible wall for my infant brother, who pounded at the very real wall beside his bed, shrieking and wailing in disgust. When my mother asked what I'd done to provoke him, I threw up my hands in mock innocence, before lowering them to retrieve the imaginary baby which lay fussing at my feet. I patted the back of my little ghost in order to induce gas and was investigating its soiled diaper when I noticed my mother's face assume an expression she reserved for unspeakable horror. I had seen this look only twice before-- once when she was caught in the path of a charging, rabid pig and once again when I told her I wanted a peach-colored velveteen blazer with matching slacks.
我回到家，向我还在婴儿期的弟弟展示隐形墙，结果他对着床边那面真实的墙壁猛敲，尖叫哭闹不止。当妈妈问我对他做了什么时，我假装无辜地摊开双手，然后放下手去抱起我脚边正在闹别扭的“隐形婴儿”。我拍着小幽灵的后背帮它排气，正准备检查它那弄脏的尿布时，发现妈妈的脸上露出了一种她平时只在极其恐怖的情况下才会有的表情。这种表情我只见过两次——一次是她遇到一头疯猪冲过来的时候，另一次是我告诉她我想要一件桃红色的天鹅绒西装外套和配套长裤的时候。
"I don't know who put you up to this," she said, "But I'll kill you myself before I watch you grow up to be a clown. You want to diaper a baby? Make yourself useful and wipe up the genuine article." She handed me my brother before turning to leave the room. Because I respected her opinion, I did as I was told, ending my career in mime with a whimper, rather than the silent bang I had hoped for.
“我不知道是谁教你这些的，”她说，“但在我看着你长成一个小丑之前，我会先亲手宰了你。你想给婴儿换尿布？去做点有用的事，把真正的脏东西擦干净。”她把弟弟塞给我，然后转身离开房间。因为我尊重她的意见，所以我照办了，以一声呜咽结束了我的哑剧生涯，而不是我希望的那种无声的爆发。
The visiting actor returned to the classroom a few months later, removing his topcoat to reveal a black body stocking worn with a putty-colored neck brace, the result of a recent automobile accident. This afternoon's task was to introduce us to the works of William Shakespeare. And once again, I was completely captivated by his charm and skill. When the words became confusing, you needed only pay attention to the actor's face and hands to know that this particular character was not just angry, but vengeful.
几个月后，那位巡回演员又回到了教室，他脱下大衣，露出里面的一件黑色紧身衣，脖子上戴着一个灰白色的颈托——那是最近一次车祸的结果。今天下午的任务是向我们介绍威廉·莎士比亚的作品。再一次，他的魅力和技巧让我彻底着迷。当语言变得难以理解时，你只需要关注演员的表情和双手，就能知道这个角色不仅是生气，而且是充满仇恨。
I loved the undercurrent of hostility that lay beneath the surface of this deceptively beautiful language. It seemed a shame that people no longer spoke this way. And I undertook a campaign to reintroduce Elizabethan English to the citizens of Raleigh.
我喜欢这种华丽辞藻表面下涌动的敌意暗流。人们不再这样说话，真是一种遗憾。于是我发起了一场运动，试图向罗利的公民重新引入伊丽莎白时代的英语。
"Perchance, fair lady, thou dost think me unduly vexed at the sorrowful state of thine quarters," I said to my mother as I ran the vacuum over the living room carpet she was inherently too lazy to bother with. "These foul specks, the evidence of life itself, have sullied not only thine shag-tempered mat, but also thine character. Be ye mad, woman? Were it a crime to neglect thine dwellings, you, my feeble-spirited mistress, would hang from the tallest venerable tree in penitence for your shameful ways.
“或许，美丽的女士，你认为我对你那杂乱的居所深感烦恼，”我一边用吸尘器打扫客厅的地毯，一边对我妈妈说，她天生就懒得去理会这些。“这些肮脏的尘埃，生命本身的证据，不仅玷污了你那多毛的垫子，也玷污了你的人格。你疯了吗，女人？如果忽视居所是一种罪行，那么你这个意志薄弱的女主人，就该被吊在最高的古树上，为你可耻的行为忏悔。”
Be there not linens to both launder and iron free of turbulence? See ye not the porcelain plates and hearty mugs waiting to be washed clean of evidence? Get thee to thine work, damnable lady, and quickly, before the products of thine very loins raise their collected fists in a spirit born of rage and indignation, forcibly coaxing the last breath from the foul chamber of thine vain and upright throat. Go now, wastrel, and get to it."
难道就没有需要洗涤和熨烫的亚麻布吗？难道你没看见那些瓷盘和厚重的马克杯正等着被洗净证据吗？快去做你的工作，可恶的女人，赶紧点，免得你亲生骨肉们的拳头因为愤怒和义愤在心中汇聚，强行夺走你那虚伪而自负的喉咙里的最后一口气。走吧，败家子，快去做事。”
This time my mother, a high school dropout, was caught off guard. Members of her immediate family had done time in some serious mental institutions. And something suggested I might be next. I could tell by the state of my room that she spent the next day searching my dresser for drugs. The clothes I took pride in neatly folding were crammed tight into the doors with no regard for color or category. I smelled the evidence of cigarettes and noticed the coffee rings left on my desk.
这一次，我妈妈，一个高中辍学者，被打了个措手不及。她的直系亲属中有几位曾在严重的精神病院里待过。某种预感暗示我可能是下一个。从我房间的状态就能看出，她第二天花了一整天翻我的梳妆台找毒品。我引以为傲精心折叠的衣服被粗鲁地塞进柜子里，根本不管颜色或类别。我闻到了香烟的味道，还注意到了桌子上留下的咖啡渍。
I loved my mother dearly. But mess with mine drawers, and ye have just made thineself an enemy. Tying a feather to the shaft of my ballpoint pen, I quilled her a letter.
我深爱着我的母亲。但要是动了我的抽屉，你就成了我的敌人。我把一根羽毛系在圆珠笔杆上，给她写了一封鹅毛笔书信。
"The thing that ye search for so desperately resideth not in mine well-ordered chambers, but in the questionable content of thine own character." I slipped the note into her purse, folded twice and sealed with wax from the candles I now used to light my room.
“你如此绝望寻找的东西，并不存在于我井然有序的房间里，而存在于你自己那充满疑点的人格之中。”我把字条叠了两次，封上蜡，塞进她的钱包里，蜡是用我平时点亮房间的蜡烛熔化的。
I took to brooding, refusing to let up until I received a copy of Shakespeare's collected plays. Reading them, though, just didn't provide the kick I'd hoped for. I found it more enjoyable to simply carry the book from room to room, occasionally skimming for fun words I might toss into my ever-fragrant vocabulary. The dinner hour became either unbearable or excruciatingly, depending on my mood.
我开始闷闷不乐，直到得到了一本莎士比亚戏剧全集才罢休。但阅读它们并没有带来我预期的那种快感。我发现把书从一个房间拿到另一个房间随便翻翻，寻找一些可以加入我那“芳香四溢”词汇库的有趣词汇反而更有趣。晚餐时间要么变得难以忍受，要么变得极其痛苦，取决于我的心情。
"Me thinks, kind sir, most gentle lady, fellow siblings all, that this barnyard fowl be most tasty and succulent, having simmered in its own sweet juices for such a time as it might take the sun to pass, rosy and full-fingered, across the plum-colored sky for the course of a twilight hour. 'Tis crisp yet juicy, this plump bird, satisfied in the company of such finely roasted neighbors. Hear me out, fine relations, and heed my words. For me thinks it adventurous, and fanciful too, to saddle mine fork with both foul and carrot at the exact same time, the twin juices blending together in a delicate harmony which doth cajole and enliven the tongue in a spirit of unbridled merriment. What say ye, fine father, sisters, and infant brother too, that we raise our flagons high in celebration of this hearty feast, prepared lovingly and with tender grace by this dutiful woman we have the good fortune to address as our wife, wench, or mother?"
“依我看，善良的先生，温婉的女士，各位兄弟姐妹，这只家禽真是美味多汁，它在自己的甜蜜汁液中炖煮了这么久，直到太阳——那红润饱满的手指——在暮色中划过那李子色的天空。这只丰满的鸟儿外酥里嫩，与其身旁烤得恰到好处的伙伴们相伴，令人心满意足。听我说，亲爱的家人，留意我的话。因为我觉得，用叉子同时叉起禽肉和胡萝卜，让两种汁液融合在一起，产生一种精致的和谐，在那肆意狂欢的氛围中引诱并活跃舌尖，这既冒险又奇幻。不知亲爱的父亲、姐妹以及尚在襁褓的弟弟意下如何？我们要不要高举酒杯，庆祝这场由这位我们有幸称为妻子、女仆或母亲的尽责女性，充满爱意与温柔准备的丰盛大餐？”
My enthusiasm knew no limits. And as a result, it quickly reached the point where my mother literally begged me to wait in the car while she stepped into the bank or the grocery store. I was at the orthodontist's office, placing a pox upon the practice of dentistry, when the visiting actor returned to our classroom.
我的热情到了无法无天的地步。结果就是，妈妈后来真的求我留在大车里，而她去银行或超市。我当时正在牙医诊所，咒骂着牙科手术，那位巡回演员又回到了教室。
"You missed it, my friend Lois said, the man was so indescribably powerful that I was practically crying. That's how brilliant he was. I can't describe it any better than that," she placed her chain in her hand and stared out the window into the parking lot. "There's absolutely nothing left for me to say about it, nothing. I could try to explain his realness, but you'd never be able to understand it."
“你错过了，我的朋友Lois说，那个人强大得难以形容，我当时差点哭了。他就是那么天才。我无法用更好的语言来形容，”她把链子放在手里，盯着窗外的停车场。“关于这件事，我真的没什么可说的了，真的。我可以试着解释他的真实感，但你永远无法理解。”
Lois and I had been friends for six months when our relationship suddenly took on a competitive edge. I'd never cared who made better grades or had the most spending money. We each had our strengths. The important thing was to honor one another for the thing they did best. Lois complained better than I did. And I respected her for that. Her grotesque excess of self-confidence allowed her to march into school wearing a rust-colored Afro wig. And I stood behind her 100%. She had more records than I did. And because she was a year older, she also knew how to drive a car and did so as if she were rushing to a fire.
Lois和我做朋友已经六个月了，我们的关系突然多了一层竞争感。我从不在乎谁成绩更好，或者谁的零花钱更多。我们各有千秋。重要的是尊重对方擅长的事情。Lois比我更会抱怨，我为此很尊重她。她那种怪诞的过度自信让她敢于戴着一顶铁锈色的非洲假发走进学校，而我百分之百支持她。她的唱片比我多。而且因为她比我大一岁，她还会开车，而且开得就像要去救火一样。
Fine, I thought, good for her. I was genuinely happy for Lois until she questioned my ability to understand the visiting actor. I was the one who identified his brilliance in the first place. Me, not her. Sure, she'd been there beside me in the classroom, but she didn't even realize that was an invisible wall until I told her. When he'd come in with his Shakespeare, she'd been just like the rest of them, laughing at his neck brace and rolling her eyes at the tangerine-sized lump in his tights. Now she was telling me that I couldn't understand him? Me think not.
好吧，我想，她高兴就好。我真心为Lois感到高兴，直到她质疑我理解那位巡回演员的能力。明明是我最先发现他的才华的。是我，不是她。没错，她当时就在教室里，但我没告诉她之前，她甚至都没意识到那是一面隐形墙。当他带着莎士比亚作品进来时，她和其他人一样，对着他的颈托大笑，对着他紧身裤里那个橘子大小的鼓包翻白眼。现在她竟然告诉我，我理解不了他？我想才不是这样。
"Honestly woman," I said to my mother on our way to the dry cleaner, "To think that this low-lying worm might speak to me of greatness as though it were a thing invisible to mine eyes is more than I can bear. Her words doth strike mine heart with the force of a punishing blow, leaving me both stunned and highly vexed too. Hear me though, for I shall bide my time quietly and with cunning, striking back at the very hour she doth least expect it. Such an affront shall not go unchallenged. Of that you may rest assured, gentle mother. My vengeance will hold the sweet taste of the ripest berry. And I shall savor it slowly and with gusto."
“老实说，女人，”我在去干洗店的路上对我妈说，“一想到这只卑微的蠕虫竟敢跟我谈论伟大，好像那是我视而不见的东西，我就无法忍受。她的话语像惩罚的重锤一样击中我的心脏，让我既震惊又恼火。不过听着，我会安静而狡猾地等待时机，在最意想不到的时候给予回击。这样的羞辱绝不能就这样算了。这点你可以放心，温婉的母亲。我的复仇会带有最成熟浆果的甜美滋味。我将慢慢地、津津有味地品尝它。”
"You'll get over it," my mother said. "Give it a few weeks and the whole thing will blow over."
“你会好起来的，”我妈说，“过几周，整件事就会平息的。”
This would become her answer to everything. She'd done some asking around and concluded that I'd been bitten by what her sister called, the drama bug. My mother was convinced that this was just a phase like all the others. A few weeks of prancing and I'd drop show business just like I had the guitar and my private detective agency. I hated having my life's ambition reduced to the level of a common cold. This wasn't a bug but a full-fledged virus. It might lay low for a year or two, but this little germ would never go away. It had nothing to do with talent. Rejection wouldn't weaken it and no amount of success could ever satisfy it.
这成了她回答所有问题的口头禅。她打听了一圈后断定，我被她姐姐所说的“戏剧迷”给咬了。我妈深信这和其他阶段一样，只是一个暂时的过程。只要让我蹦跶几周，我就像放弃吉他和我的私人侦探事务所一样，放弃演艺事业。我讨厌将我的人生抱负降低到普通感冒的水平。这不是感冒，而是全面的病毒。它可能会潜伏一两年，但这种小病菌永远不会消失。这与天赋无关。排斥不会削弱它，任何成功也无法满足它。
The drama bug strikes hardest with Jews, homosexuals, and plump women who wear their hair in bangs. These are people who, for one reason or another, desperately crave attention. I would later learn that it's a bad idea to gather more than two of these people in an enclosed area for any amount of time. "Stage" is not an actual place but rather a state of mind related to one's whereabouts during the time you're not asleep. "Audience" defines anyone pausing long enough for you to interrupt. We were a string of light bulbs left burning 24 hours a day. And as a result, our exhausted public soon stopped wondering what all the fuss was about.
“戏剧迷”对犹太人、同性恋者和留着刘海的丰满女性打击最重。这些人因为某种原因，极其渴望得到关注。后来我得知，把超过两个这样的人长时间关在一个封闭空间里是个糟糕的主意。“舞台”不是一个具体的地点，而是当你没睡觉时，你所处状态的一种心理状态。“观众”定义了任何为你提供了足够长的停顿时间，让你去打断他们的人。我们是一串24小时开着的灯泡。结果，我们那疲惫的观众很快就不再关心这些动静到底是为了什么。
[MUSIC- "BRUSH UP YOUR SHAKESPEARE" BY CYBILL SHEPHERD]
[音乐 - Cybill Shepherd演唱的《重温莎士比亚》]
David Sedaris' story of getting the drama bug will continue later in our program after another story documenting everyday life in these United States. This recording, by the way, is Cybill Shepherd, 1974, an album called, Cybill Does it to Cole Porter.
David Sedaris关于成为戏剧迷的故事将在我们节目稍后继续，在另一个记录美国日常生活的真实故事之后。顺便说一下，这段录音是Cybill Shepherd在1974年的专辑《Cybill Does it to Cole Porter》。
Act Two. "Lost in Yonkers." There are only 13 rehearsals left for the Oak Park and River Forest High School production of Neil Simon's play, Lost in Yonkers . And still people do not know their lines.
第二幕。“迷失在扬克斯”。离橡树园与河森林高中排演Neil Simon的剧作《迷失在扬克斯》只剩13次排练了。大家仍然不熟悉台词。
Maybe he's a thief too, mama. But at least he loved me enough to want to help me. Yeah, we're alive but that's all we are. Aaron and Rose are the lucky ones.
也许他也是个小偷，妈妈。但至少他足够爱我，想帮我。是的，我们活着，但也就仅此而已。Aaron和Rose才是幸运儿。
No, don't say that to me, Bella. God.
不，别那样对我说话，Bella。天哪。
To play grandma, Tiffany Moore uses this metal cane during rehearsals. And it's become this all-purpose prop that she uses for expressing her moods, waving it around in the air, pointing it at people. At this point, she slams it against the ground. The assistant director, the stage manager, and the director, Mr. Simon, sit in the audience with scripts in hand and feed lines.
为了扮演祖母，Tiffany Moore在排练时使用这根金属拐杖。它成了多功能的道具，用来表达她的情绪，在空中挥舞，指着别人。此刻，她将它重重摔在地上。助理导演、舞台监督和导演Simon先生坐在观众席上，手里拿着剧本，负责提醒台词。
Not that hard a line. No, don't say that. Please god. Don't say that to me, Bella.
台词没那么难。不，别那么说。求你了，上帝。别那样对我说话，Bella。
No, don't say that to me. Please god. Don't say that to me, Bella.
不，别那样对我说话。求你了，上帝。别那样对我说话，Bella。
I'm sorry, Mama. I didn't mean to hurt you.
对不起，妈妈。我不是故意要伤害你的。
Yes you do.
不，你是故意的。
Actually, the show's not in bad shape. The actors are mastering their accents, blocking, basic characters, they're all down. Tiffany's on stage with Laura Lopardo and both of them are old pros, veterans of seven other high school plays. Laura plays Bella, a slightly retarded 35-year-old woman. Laura is one of the strongest performers in this cast. She's very soulful. But she's also Mr. Simon's biggest worry. When he critiques the actors at the end of each rehearsal, he mostly tells the other actors to watch their accents or try some little moment a little differently. But at rehearsal after rehearsal he has the same criticism for Laura. Her character is still not there, he says.
实际上，剧排得还不错。演员们掌握了口音、走位、基本角色，一切都准备好了。Tiffany和Laura Lopardo一起在舞台上，她们都是老手，都有过七次高中戏剧表演的经验。Laura扮演Bella，一个略显智障的35岁女性。Laura是剧组中表现最强的演员之一。她非常有灵性，但她也是Simon先生最担心的人。每场排练结束时，他评论演员们，大部分是告诉其他人注意口音或尝试不同的表演方式。但每场排练，他都对Laura提出同样的批评。他说，她的角色还没完全进入状态。
It just-- it just-- she's just still too smart. You're too smart and she's coming out too smart. There needs to be more of--
就是——就是——她还是太聪明了。你太聪明了，表演出来也显得太聪明了。需要有更多的……
I try to think about it. It's easier when I say [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE], lines like that are a little more easier.
我尽量去想。当我念[无法听清的短语]的时候就容易些，像那样的台词更容易。
Right, exactly. That sort of represents her level.
对，没错。那代表了她的水平。
But then when it's the whole, I'm not crying. That's so hard. I don't really know how to work in stupidity.
但当那整段我不哭的时候，真的太难了。我不知道怎么去演那种愚笨感。
Play it more childlike all the way through, Mr. Simon tells Laura, and those moments will come.
全程演得更孩子气一点，Simon先生告诉Laura，那些时刻自然就会出现。
So your first line, for instance, Jay? It's me, Aunt Bella, can I come in? Guess who forgot how to open the door? I forgot my key.
那么你的第一句台词，比如Jay？是我，Bella姨妈，我可以进来吗？猜猜谁忘了怎么开门？我忘了带钥匙。
Let us in. Hey, Charlie. Come on, let us in. Thank you. Bye, you guys. Let me in. You're a goof.
让我们进去。嘿，Charlie。来，让我们进去。谢谢。再见，伙计们。让我进去。你真是个笨蛋。
School is officially closed. But finally, someone comes to open up the door for the cast of Lost in Yonkers. They rehearse three times over spring break and two times the weekend before the show. And although it is a gorgeous spring day outside, everyone shows up in the dimly lit school hallway. And they seem happy about it.
学校正式放假了。但最终，有人来为《迷失在扬克斯》的剧组开门。春假期间他们排练了三次，演出前那个周末排练了两次。尽管外面是灿烂的春日，大家还是出现在阴暗的学校走廊里。他们看起来对此很开心。
You have to look--
你必须看看——
Look at this.
看看这个。
--To understand the pulp in this orange juice. Check out the rim of my glass.
——来了解这橙汁里的果肉。看看我杯子的边缘。
Look at this.
看看这个。
Mr. Simon bought of the wrong kind of orange juice for his cast this particular day. And Laura and Tiffany are teasing him about that. The cast has been together for five weeks. And they're getting so familiar with each other that they're beginning to function as a kind of hilarious, dysfunctional family.
Simon先生这一天给演员们买错了橙汁。Laura和Tiffany正在拿这个取笑他。剧组在一起五个星期了。他们变得如此熟悉，以至于开始表现得像一个搞笑的、功能失调的家庭。
You don't understand that-- you know orange juice really has pulp.
你不明白——你知道橙汁真的有果肉。
Not this much.
没这么多。
It is slime.
简直是烂泥。
Before rehearsal can begin there have to be, of course, announcements. Katie has ordered Lost in Yonkers t-shirts for the cast. T-shirts from the various plays that they've been in seem to make up a significant part of the daily high school wardrobe of this cast.
在开始排练之前，当然要先发布通知。Katie为剧组订购了《迷失在扬克斯》的T恤。在这个剧组，参加过的各种戏剧的T恤似乎构成了他们日常高中着装的重要部分。
And don't stiff me on this. Because I don't want to put $15 in for people who say they're going to buy a t-shirt.
别在这件事上赖账。因为我不希望为那些说要买T恤却不给钱的人垫付15美元。
There will not be-- if you do not leave your $15. When do you need it? Tuesday at the latest?
不会有——如果你不留下你的15美元的话。你什么时候要？最晚周二？
Monday.
周一。
Monday at the latest. This is not a bank. This is not a bank, that's right.
最晚周一。这不是银行。这不是银行，没错。
This is actually a little joke. "This is not a bank," is a line from the play. As the cast spends more and more time together, they're starting to form their own little subculture full of references to the play and jokes that only they get. The Lost in Yonkers actors can get a laugh out of each other simply by saying the phrase, General Erwin Rommel, or, who was the friend?
这其实是个小笑话。“这不是银行”是剧中的一句台词。随着剧组成员在一起的时间越来越多，他们开始形成自己的小亚文化，充满了剧中只有他们才懂的梗。《迷失在扬克斯》的演员们只要说出“埃尔温·隆美尔将军”或者“那个朋友是谁？”这样的短语，就能逗乐彼此。
Who was the friend?
那个朋友是谁？
And, touchingly, it's hard for them not to use these phrases out in their regular lives as well with people who don't know that these are lines from the play. They don't know that these are jokes.
最感人的是，他们很难不在现实生活中与那些不知道这些是剧中台词的人使用这些短语。他们不知道这都是笑话。
That when I yell at my mom these days I use lines from the show. We were talking about my grandma and I go, Grandma's crazy, mom. Where did that horse fall, on her head? I was quoting the show. It's getting really scary.
这几天我冲我妈妈大喊大叫时，用的全是剧里的台词。我们正在谈论我祖母，我就说，祖母疯了，妈。那是哪匹马摔的，摔在她脑袋上了吗？我在引用剧里的台词。这真的越来越可怕了。
And if all this just makes the drama kids seem like obnoxious weirdos, well you try reciting the same text over and over, three hours a day, for five weeks. And see if it isn't running through your head all the time, laying in wait for some conversational gap into which it can drive its powerful force.
如果这一切让这些戏剧孩子看起来像古怪的讨人厌鬼，那么你尝试一下每天花三个小时，连续五周重复同样的台词看看。看看它是不是整天在你脑子里打转，就等着某个谈话空隙，好把那股强大的力量钻进去。
At one point, Kim got the idea that they should all go out to eat together at a restaurant in character. As Tiffany explains, they did drive together in one car, piling into somebody's tiny compact whatever, asked for a table for seven for the Kurnitz family, which is their name in the play. But then they kind of lost their nerve. They didn't really play the characters.
有一次，Kim提议大家应该一起以剧中角色的身份去餐厅吃饭。正如Tiffany所解释的，他们确实开着一辆车，挤进某个人的小型紧凑车里，要求给“Kurnitz一家”（他们在剧中的名字）一张七人的桌子。但后来他们没胆量演下去了。他们没能真正去表演这些角色。
Instead we just did our accents when we ordered the food. And the waitress kind of looked at us funny. And that was about it. She didn't really care. But we all thought it was funny. We all thought we were really pretty funny.
取而代之的是，我们在点餐时用了口音。服务员觉得我们很奇怪，也就那样了。她并不真正在乎。但我们都觉得很有意思，我们都觉得我们表现得太搞笑了。
The youngest members of the cast are Ben Myers and Max Stewart. They're freshmen. Though, Max is quick to tell you, if you should ask him, that he's been in lots of plays, drama club shows in grade school, stretching all the way back to his role as Joseph in his first grade Christmas pageant.
剧组最年轻的成员是Ben Myers和Max Stewart。他们是新生。不过，如果你问Max的话，他会很快告诉你，他演过很多戏，小学时参加过戏剧俱乐部的演出，一直追溯到他一年级圣诞庆典里扮演的约瑟夫。
And then I went to junior high. And they have a much more elaborate, much more professional program at the junior high. And I did a whole bunch of shows there. I got kind of discouraged after I didn't make West Side Story . But I just bounced right back and went to the next audition.
然后我上了初中。初中的课程要精细和专业得多。我在那里演了一大堆戏。在没选上《西区故事》后我有点沮丧。但我很快调整过来，又去参加了下一次试镜。
Max, when you talk about this, you sound like such an old pro.
Max，当你谈论这些时，听起来简直像个老戏骨。
Well, I don't want to sound like I've been in the business for that long. But it's been a few-- it's been a few years. I've seen a lot. I've done a lot. But I've still got a long way to go. I actually-- I don't like to get all cocky and toot my own horn here, but I did just-- I got asked by someone to understudy for a role at The Village Players theatre, which I was very, very honored to do. It was really a lot of fun.
嗯，我不想听起来好像我在这个行当里待了很久一样。但已经过了几年了。我见过很多，也做过很多。但我还有很长的路要走。我其实——我不喜欢自大也不想自吹自擂，但我刚刚受邀在Village Players剧院为一个角色做替补，我感到非常、非常荣幸。那真的很有趣。
The Village Players. Sure, they're not a real professional company. Sure, they're out in the suburbs, they're not down in the city. Sure, they're all volunteers. But they're adults. Not many boys go out for drama at Oak Park and River Forest high school. And directors often have trouble filling the male roles. And part of being in high school drama means putting up with friends who do not look too kindly on the entire endeavor.
Village Players。当然，他们不是真正的专业剧团。当然，他们在郊区，不在城里。当然，他们都是志愿者。但他们是成年人。在橡树园与河森林高中，没多少男生参加戏剧表演。导演们常常难以填补男性角色。参加高中戏剧表演的一部分意义，就是不得不忍受那些对这种努力并不友善的朋友。
I think a lot of guys-- almost all the guys see it is a real wussy thing to do, maybe. You know what I mean? Have you felt that, Max? That people are like that?
我想很多男生——几乎所有的男生都觉得这有点娘娘腔。你知道我的意思吗？Max，你有这种感觉吗？人们是这样的吗？
Like Ben said, they think it's a wussy thing because they think theater is one step away from like ballet.
像Ben说的那样，他们觉得这是娘娘腔的行为，因为他们认为戏剧离芭蕾舞只有一步之遥。
There's a terrible stereotype about all guys in theatre are gay. And it's just-- it's awful because--
关于“所有戏剧男演员都是同性恋”有一种极其糟糕的偏见。这真的很恶心，因为——
Because we're not gay.
因为我们不是同性恋。
An awkward silence falls amongst the three of us for a moment. Ben seems to know that what they've just said is a little strange, maybe a little offensive, because he makes a noise as if he's about to say something else. Then he looks at Max, looks down, rocks in place moment, and decides that he's not going to say anything.
我们三人之间陷入了片刻的尴尬沉默。本似乎意识到他们刚才说的话有些奇怪，也许还有点冒犯，于是他发出了一声响动，好像正要再说点什么。但他看了看马克斯，低下头，在原地晃了晃，决定还是什么都不说了。
This show, it's definitely probably the smallest part I've ever had. So it's a lot of waiting around, which can be difficult, and just kind of watching everybody else and wishing that I was up there with them.
这场演出，绝对是我演过戏份最少的一部了。所以需要大量的等待，这很难熬，只能看着别人表演，心里想着要是能和他们一起站在台上就好了。
Kim Plostina plays Aunt Gertie in the show. It's a small role, but the kind of small character part that can steal entire scenes. Kim wants to be an actress. And, while most of the cast is considering acting and theater as one option for their lives, Kim is certain. But she suffers from a handicap that the others do not. Her father is a professional actor. He does a lot of college industrial films.
金·普洛斯蒂娜在剧中饰演格蒂阿姨。这是一个小角色，但却是那种能抢尽风头的龙套。金想成为一名演员。虽然剧组里大多数人只是把表演和戏剧当作人生的一个选项，但金非常坚定。然而，她有一个别人没有的障碍。她的父亲是一名职业演员。他经常接拍一些大学里的工业宣传片。
Actually, he discourages me from it because he doesn't want me to get hurt, is his reason. But if anything, that's just harder. Because then I always feel like I have to prove myself to him too. I really wish he'd encourage me since it's kind of hypocritical since he does the same thing.
其实他并不鼓励我这样做，理由是他不想让我受伤。但如果非要说的话，这反而更困难。因为这样我就总觉得我也必须向他证明自己。我真希望他能鼓励我，毕竟他自己也做着同样的事，这样做有点虚伪。
Maybe he seems how hard it is for him.
也许他看出了这行对他来说有多难。
Oh yeah. Oh he's definitely had a hard time at it. Especially since a couple of his friends have made it big time, and then he hasn't. So that's hard for him to watch.
哦，是的。他确实经历过一段艰难的时期。尤其是他的几个朋友都大红大紫了，而他却没有。所以这对那个他来说很难面对。
Years ago, at the Shady Lane Theater in Marengo, Illinois, her father was in shows with a young David Hasselhoff. And seeing his daughter fall in love with the theater-- it must be a kind of ordeal for him, the kind of test that every parent dreads. Should he discourage her in the thing she loves if it worries him so? But lately, Kim says, he's gone through a big change. He told her that he's going to introduce her to an agent. He's going to help her get auditions.
多年前，在伊利诺伊州马伦戈的树荫巷剧院，她父亲曾与年轻的大卫·哈塞尔霍夫同台演出。看着女儿爱上戏剧——对他来说一定是一种考验，一种每个家长都害怕面对的试炼。他是否应该因为担心，而去阻挠女儿做她热爱的事情？但金说，最近他发生了巨大的转变。他告诉她，他打算把她介绍给一位经纪人，还要帮她争取试镜机会。
And then, my dad has said to me that he's been watching me on stage and sometimes tears come to his eyes. Just for him to say that, and since he always is discouraging me. For him to tell me that, it means a lot.
然后，我爸爸跟我说，他一直看着我在舞台上的表现，有时会热泪盈眶。能听到他说这些，考虑到他平时总是在打压我，能听到他这么说，对我意义重大。
Tell me where.
告诉我哪里有问题。
Well, you have a problem.
好吧，你有麻烦了。
I know I have a problem. I'm trying to solve it. And I'd appreciate any help you might give me from standing back there.
我知道我有麻烦了。我正在努力解决它。如果站在那边能帮上忙，我会很感激的。
No that's worse. That's worse.
不，那样更糟。那样更糟。
Six days before opening night, they run the play for the first time on the stage with the beginnings of a set, chairs representing where furniture will go. And there is a problem, there seems to be no way to put a table and sofabed on the stage and still have room for entrances and exits. So the cast converges on stage.
在首演之夜的前六天，他们第一次在舞台上排练了这部剧，舞台刚搭了个雏形，用椅子代表家具的位置。结果出了个问题，舞台上似乎没法既放下一张桌子和一张沙发床，又留出供演员上下的通道。于是，演职人员们纷纷涌向舞台。
OK, I'm as tall as my arms are, right? And I know I'm exactly as tall as--
好了，我的臂展就是我的身高，对吧？我知道我刚好和——
This is where the sofabed ends.
沙发床到这里就结束了。
This would be the furthest corner down.
这是最靠下的角落。
Jeff. Jeff, come here. Come here.
杰夫，杰夫，过来。过来。
You need some male assistance?
你们需要男性支援吗？
No, I need somebody that's the largest person that's going to be on this bed.
不，我需要一个将会在这张床上躺着的人里个子最大的。
OK, lay on the floor. Put your head under the chair.
好了，躺在地板上。把头钻到椅子下面。
At this point, a surreal scene gets even more surreal. For the next eight minutes, Jeff lays on the floor, his head under a chair, as six people walk around him arguing. He is placid. He is happy. He is the consummate professional. And this is part of why you do theater in high school. It's not just the place where you can get applause and approval. As Tiffany says, this is the most intense problem solving, the most serious, concentrated work that she does in high school.
此时，这荒诞的场景变得更加荒诞了。在接下来的八分钟里，杰夫躺在地板上，头伸在椅子底下，六个人围着他争论。他很平静。他很乐意。他是一个完美的专业人士。这就是为什么要在高中参加戏剧社的部分原因。它不仅仅是一个能让你获得掌声和认可的地方。正如蒂芙尼所说，这是她在高中所做的最激烈的解决问题的过程，是最严肃、最集中的工作。
But for example, do things happen in class that are as intense as that little discussion in your real classes?
但比如，在你的现实课堂上，会发生像刚才那种讨论一样激烈的事情吗？
No, never. The most debated thing that ever has happened in any of my classes is whether or not everyone did the homework or not. It's just so much more intense because it's a thinking and a physical thing and you just do it. And you do it over and over and over again until it's perfected.
不，从来没有。我在课堂上经历过最激烈的辩论，就是关于大家到底做没做作业。戏剧排练要激烈得多，因为它既是思考过程也是体力活，你必须一直做。一遍又一遍地重复，直到做到完美。
Trixie, can you hear me? I've been giving warrants.
特里克西，你能听到我说话吗？我一直在发传票。
He gave you a warrant.
他给了你一张传票。
I'm not hearing you.
我没听到。
You're not?
你没听到？
No.
没有。
In the sound closet are the crew guys, the techies, who run the lights and the sound and build the set and handle the props. Anybody who's ever done theater anywhere will tell you about the ancient rivalry between cast and crew. There are 45 crew members for three theaters at Oak Park and River Forest High School. And they constitute kind of a permanent government. Actors come and go. Shows come and go. But crew members, they're there every week. And frankly, it can be a little irritating to them that the actors think that they're all that, when the crew really runs the show. At this school, they all have special hall passes. They all answer to a teacher that they all refer to simply as, "Boss." They all insist that you spell crew, C-R-U-E, as in Motley Crue. And don't forget that umlaut. Senior Jon Huber has done 57 shows.
在音控室里的是剧组人员，技术人员，他们负责灯光、音响、布景和道具。任何在任何地方搞过戏剧的人都会告诉你剧组与演职人员之间那古老的竞争关系。橡树园和河森林高中有三个剧场，共有45名工作人员。他们构成了某种永久性的政府。演员来来去去，剧目换了又换，但工作人员每周都在那儿。坦率地说，演员们总觉得自己了不起，而实际上是工作人员在运作整场演出，这让他们感到有些恼火。在这所学校，他们都有特殊的通行证。他们都听命于一位老师，大家干脆称他为“老大”。他们都坚持要把剧组拼作“CRUE”，就像“克鲁小丑乐队”（Motley Crue）那样，而且别忘了那个分音符。高年级的乔恩·胡伯已经参加过57场演出了。
Everything on crue is tradition. Everything. In our yearbook pictures we have pictures of our arms crossed right over left with a cut-out of a dinosaur and a stand-up light. And the dinosaur's name is Ralph. And the stand-up light's named Stanley. And we have literally turned around and walked out of pictures for our yearbook because they said we couldn't have it.
在Crue，一切皆是传统。每一件事。在年鉴照片里，我们有双臂交叉、左手压在右手上的照片，旁边还有一个恐龙剪纸和一盏立式灯。恐龙叫拉尔夫，灯叫斯坦利。我们曾真的因为他们说不能带这些道具，就转身直接走出了拍摄现场，拒绝拍照。
Jon says there's a lot of prejudice against crew. Some teachers think that they're slackers, and smokers, and drug users. People don't notice the charity work crew does. People haven't noticed that so many more girls are now on crew. Though that does threaten some crew traditions.
乔恩说，人们对剧组有很多偏见。有些老师认为他们是懒鬼、烟民和瘾君子。人们没有注意到剧组所做的慈善工作。人们也没注意到现在剧组里有这么多女生。尽管这确实威胁到了一些剧组的传统。
Some of the problems that we've had is female crew members have coddled some of the younger-classmen. And usually it's been our intent to kind of rule with an iron fist.
我们遇到的一些问题是，女性工作人员对一些低年级学生过于溺爱了。而通常我们的初衷是铁腕统治。
Do you think there's anything positive about the way the girls want to do it?
你觉得女生们做事的方式有什么积极的一面吗？
Oh yeah. They work a whole lot more than we do.
哦，有。她们比我们勤快多了。
At that point, he turned back to his own work. Cues were being missed and opening night was just a few nights away. We arrive there in a minute when our program continues.
就在那时，他转回去继续忙自己的工作。演出节奏错乱，首演夜只剩几天了。稍后我们的节目继续，我们会在那时回到现场。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Our story about the Oak Park and River Forest High School production of Lost in Yonkers continues with opening night.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们关于橡树园和河森林高中《纽约里的迷失》剧组的故事，将继续报道首演之夜。
Aahhh. Yeah I know. My hands are sweating.
啊。是的，我知道。我的手在冒汗。
Minutes before the curtain rises, Laura is still being made up. She's sick with what turns out later to be pnemonia. Mr. Simon has given her another set of pep talks about making her character childlike and not too smart. She shivers and runs to the stage. No opening night is complete without some kind of small crisis. For Lost in Yonkers , it involves a form-fitting, sleeveless t-shirt that Jeff is supposed to wear on stage.
帷幕拉开前几分钟，劳拉还在化妆。她生病了，后来发现是肺炎。西蒙先生又给她打了一次气，让她把角色演得更孩子气一些，不要太聪明。她哆嗦着跑向舞台。没有哪场首演之夜是不出点小意外的。对于《纽约里的迷失》，意外发生在一件杰夫要在台上穿的修身无袖T恤上。
Jeff, get used to the idea. You're wearing it. You're wearing the dego tee. You have to.
杰夫，习惯它吧。你得穿。你得穿上那件“意大利佬”T恤。你必须穿。
I can't, come on.
我不能，别这样。
You have to.
你必须穿。
It's tighter than hell.
这衣服紧得要死。
I don't care. You have to.
我不在乎。你必须穿。
There are two types of actors, the kind who'd love nothing more than to reveal more of their own bodies on stage and the kind who can get a little self-conscious. Jeff is squarely in that second camp. He thinks he's too big for a tight t-shirt. And on the side of the dressing room, he sits, muttering bitterly that wearing the t-shirt will hurt his performance. Everyone goes backstage. It's all shadows and darkness and the dim, blue work lights. For six weeks, they've planned for this moment and practiced for it and wondered about it. And now, for the first time, they get to see if they were right about what would make sense to the audience. And early in the first scene, it happens. They get their first laugh.
演员分两类，一种是恨不得在台上展示更多身体部位的，另一种是会感到有些难为情的。杰夫显然属于后者。他觉得穿这件紧身T恤对他来说太显眼了。他坐在更衣室边上，苦涩地嘟囔着穿这件T恤会影响他的发挥。所有人都去了后台。到处都是阴影、黑暗和昏暗的蓝色工作灯。六周来，他们为这一刻筹划、练习、揣摩。现在，他们第一次能看到，他们对于什么能让观众买账的设想是否正确。在第一场戏刚开始不久，效果就出现了。他们赢得了第一次笑声。
They laughed. They laughed. Yes.
他们笑了。他们笑了。太好了。
A few scenes later, Jeff, who's playing a small-time Jewish gangster, is supposed to strip to his sleeveless t-shirt. He unbuttons his outer shirt, revealing the tight t-shirt underneath. And there he stops. He never takes off his outer shirt. His character, Uncle Louie, simply decides to climb in bed wearing a dress shirt. Backstage, I catch up with him.
几场戏过后，扮演小混混的杰夫本该脱掉外衣，换上那件无袖T恤。他解开了外衣的扣子，露出了里面的紧身T恤。但他停在那里，并没有脱掉外衣。他饰演的角色路易叔叔，干脆穿着正装衬衫躺到了床上。在后台，我追上了他。
Mr. Simon is going to kill me but-- that's not a Louie-like thing to do. But you know what? I don't think anybody out there really cares and is paying that much attention to me wearing a dress shirt when I go to bed. If it makes me do better, I'm going to do it.
西蒙先生会杀了我的，但是——这不是路易会做的事。但你知道吗？我觉得台下的观众根本不在乎，也没那么注意我睡觉时是不是还穿着正装衬衫。如果这样能让我演得更好，我就要这么做。
During intermission, Mr. Simon came backstage and congratulated all the actors. And he told Jeff that he looked ridiculous. Still, Jeff got more laughs than anyone in the cast. And Mr. Simon resolved to get him a looser-fitting t-shirt for future performances. Opening night, by any measure, was a wildly successful night of theater. They all got laughs. Everyone kept their accents. Everyone remembered their lines. And while everyone was good, Laura, Tiffany, and Jeff were stand-outs.
中场休息时，西蒙先生来到后台祝贺所有演员。他告诉杰夫他看起来很滑稽。尽管如此，杰夫得到的笑声却是全剧组最多的。西蒙先生决定在接下来的演出中为他找一件更宽松的T恤。首演之夜，从任何标准来看，都是一场极其成功的演出。他们都赢得了笑声，所有人都保持住了口音，所有人都记住了台词。虽然每个人表现都很棒，但劳拉、蒂芙尼和杰夫尤为出色。
Bella, sweatheart, don't go to that movie anymore. And don't see that fella again. He may be very nice. But he sounds like he's got a lot of wacky ideas. Do you know what I mean, sweetheart?
贝拉，亲爱的，别再去那家电影院了。也别再见那个男人了。他可能人很好，但他听起来满脑子怪点子。你明白我的意思吗，亲爱的？
Jay, Arty, you said you'd support me. You said you'd back me up. You promised.
杰，阿蒂，你们说过会支持我的。你们说过会做我的后盾。你们答应过的。
Back you up with what? The restaurant? The money? Is that what this guy is after?
支持什么？那家餐厅？钱吗？这家伙图的是这些吗？
He wants more than that.
他想要的不仅于此。
What could possibly be more than that, Bella?
还有什么能比那些更多呢，贝拉？
Me. He loves me. He wants to marry me. I want to marry him. I want to have his children. I want my own babies.
我。他爱我。他想娶我。我想嫁给他。我想生下他的孩子。我想要自己的孩子。
Jesus Christ.
天哪。
During the big dramatic scenes between Laura and Tiffany, it was just like Mr. Simon predicted. You could hear a pin drop. The audience was that quiet. And after the last scene, after the bows, they run from the dressing room, up some stairs, through a door, and out into the lobby where their friends and families are.
在劳拉和蒂芙尼之间的那几场重头戏中，正如西蒙先生预料的那样。你可以听见针掉在地上的声音。观众安静极了。最后一幕结束后，谢幕之后，他们从更衣室跑出来，爬上楼梯，穿过一扇门，来到大厅，朋友和家人们都在那儿。
You were so good.
你演得太好了。
Mr. Simon found them all. He told them the show went just as he'd dreamt of. And when he spotted Laura, he hugged her.
西蒙先生找到了他们。他告诉他们，演出效果和他梦里想的一模一样。当他看到劳拉时，他拥抱了她。
Well-- oh my god-- I don't know what to say to you. You were so fabulous. That scene with you and Mama was-- you blew me away. Every moment tonight was perfect. It was the best you've ever been. I mean, I was crying through half of it. I'm so grateful. You have come so far. It really was-- it really was.
噢——天哪——我不知道该说什么。你太棒了。你和妈妈的那场戏——你彻底震撼了我。今晚每一个瞬间都完美无缺。这是你表现最好的一次。我是说，我有一半的时间都在流泪。我太感激了。你已经进步了这么多。真的，真的是这样。
And while they stood in the lobby, a pair of young girls, someone's sisters, ran up to the different performers, thrilled, starstruck. They said a few words and ran off, nervous and excited.
当他们站在大厅里时，一对年轻女孩——某人的姐妹，跑向不同的演员，激动不已，如同看到了偶像。她们说了几句话就跑开了，又紧张又兴奋。
[MUSIC- "SHOWTIME" BY SAMMY DAVIS, JR.]
[音乐 - 萨米·戴维斯二世的《表演时刻》]
It's This American Life , our special drama bug edition. And now we continue our dramatic little presentation with David Sedaris, the second half of his story.
这里是《美国生活》，我们的“戏剧虫”特别版。现在我们继续通过大卫·塞达里斯的故事，带来下半场的戏剧性小呈现。
I had the drama bug and Lois had a car. This being the case, I quickly forgave her when informed that the visiting actor had scheduled a production of Hamlet set to take place at the amphitheatre of the Raleigh Rose Garden. He, himself, would direct and play the title role. But the other parts were up for grabs. We went to the audition, and, because we were the youngest, Lois and I were assigned the roles of the traveling players Hamlet uses to bate his Uncle Claudius. It wasn't the part I was hoping for, but I accepted it with a quiet dignity. I still had a few speeches and planned to use them to the best of my ability, outshining the other actors who were all much older than I.
那时我有戏剧瘾，而洛伊斯有辆车。既然如此，当得知那位客座演员计划在罗利玫瑰园的露天剧场排演《哈姆雷特》时，我很快就原谅了她。他将亲自执导并出演主角。但其他角色待定。我们去参加了试镜，因为我们年纪最小，洛伊斯和我被分配到了哈姆雷特用来引诱他叔叔克劳狄斯的“旅行剧团”角色。这并不是我期望的角色，但我还是平静地接受了，并带着尊严去面对。我依然有几句台词，并计划尽我所能发挥，盖过那些比我年长得多的演员。
They were in their 20s and 30s and carried years of experience in such long-running outdoor dramas as The Lost Colony and Tender is the Lamb . These were professionals and I hoped to benefit from their experience, sitting literally at their feet as the director paced the lip of the stage, addressing his clenched fist as, "poor Yorick."
他们都在二三十岁，在《迷失的殖民地》和《温柔是羔羊》这类长演不衰的户外剧中积累了多年经验。他们是专业人士，我希望能从他们身上学到东西，坐在他们脚边，听着导演在舞台边缘踱步，对着握紧的拳头练习：“可怜的约里克。”
I worshipped these people. Lois slept with them. By the second week of rehearsal, she had taken up with Laertes, who she claimed had a real way with the sword. Unlike me, she was embraced by the older crowd, attending late-night keg parties with Polonius and Ophelia, driving to the lake with the director while Gertrude and Rosenkrantz made out in the backseat.
我崇拜这些人，而洛伊斯则和他们睡在一起。到了排练的第二周，她就和雷欧提斯搞上了，她说雷欧提斯用剑很有招数。与我不同，她被那些年长的人接纳了，参加波洛涅斯和奥菲莉亚举办的深夜酒会，和导演一起开车去湖边，而格特鲁德和罗森格兰兹则在后座亲热。
The killer was that Lois was nowhere near as committed as I was. Her drama bug was the equivalent of a 24-hour-flu. Yet there she was, swimming naked with the director himself, while I practiced lines alone in my room.
最要命的是，洛伊斯根本没我那么投入。她的戏剧瘾就相当于一场24小时的流感。然而她却能和导演本人一起裸泳，而我只能在房间里独自练习台词。
As traveling players, it was decided that we would make our entrance tumbling onto the stage. When Lois complained that the grass was irritating her skin, the director examined the wee pimples on her back and decided that, rather than tumbling, the players would enter skipping. I had practiced my tumble until my brain lost its mooring and could be heard rattling in my skull. And now, on the basis of one complaint, we were skipping.
作为旅行剧团的成员，我们被要求以翻跟头的姿势上台。当洛伊斯抱怨草地刺激她的皮肤时，导演检查了她背上那几个小红疹，便决定我们不用翻跟头了，改为跳跃进场。我练习翻跟头练到脑子都快震得移位了，甚至能听到它在我颅骨里晃荡的声音。而现在，仅仅因为一个人的抱怨，我们就要改为跳着进场了。
He'd already cut out all of my speeches, leaving me with one line, "Aye, my Lord." While the other actors strolled the rose gardens memorizing their vengeful soliloquies, I skipped back and forth across the parking lot whispering, "Aye, my Lord. Aye, my Lord." Lois felt silly skipping and spoke to the director, who praised her instincts and announced that henceforth, the players would enter walking.
他已经剪掉了我所有的台词，只给我留了一句：“是的，我的大人。”当其他演员在玫瑰园里散步背诵他们复仇的独白时，我在停车场来回蹦跳，低声念着：“是的，我的大人。是的，我的大人。”洛伊斯觉得跳着走很傻，便跟导演说了，导演称赞她的直觉敏锐，并宣布从今往后，剧团成员改为走路进场。
The less I had to do, the more my fellow actors used me as a personal slave. I would have been happy to help them run lines. But instead, they wanted me to polish their crowns or trot out to the car and search the floorboards for their dagger.
我做的事情越少，我的同行演员越把我当成私人奴隶。我本乐意帮他们对台词，但他们却想要我去擦亮他们的皇冠，或者跑腿去车里在脚垫底下找他们的匕首。
"Looking for something to do? You can help Dugan glow tape the stage," the director said. "You can chase the spiders out of the dressing room, or better yet, run to the store. Who wants drinks?"
“没事做吗？你可以帮杜根给舞台贴荧光带，”导演说。“你可以把更衣室里的蜘蛛赶走，或者更好的是，去商店跑一趟。谁想喝饮料？”
Not only did Lois lay in the shade doing nothing, but she was the first one to hand me a $20 bill when placing an order for a $0.30 candy bar. During rehearsal breaks, she huddled with the actors while I was off anchoring ladders for one of the technicians. When it came time for our big scene, Lois recited her lines as if she were reading the words from the surface of some distant billboard. She squinted and paused between syllables, punctuating each word with a question mark. If the director had a problem with her performance, he kept it to himself.
洛伊斯不仅待在阴凉处无所事事，而且在我帮她买价值30美分的糖果时，她是第一个甩给我20美元纸币的人。排练休息时，她和演员们聚在一起，而我却在为其中一个技术人员固定梯子。轮到我们的大场面时，洛伊斯背台词的样子，就像是在读遥远广告牌上的文字。她眯着眼，在音节之间停顿，每个词后面都像是带个问号。如果导演对她的表演有什么不满，他也憋着没说。
I, on the other hand-- I needed to remove the sweater from around my neck, walk slower, and drop the accent. It might have been easier to accept the criticism had he spread it around a little, but that seemed unlikely. She could enter the stage with a slice of pizza in one hand and a Dr. Pepper in the other and that was fine, Lois, just great.
反观我——我得摘下脖子上的毛衣，走得更慢点，还得去掉口音。如果他能把批评分摊一点给别人，我可能更容易接受，但那是不可能的。她可以一手拿着披萨，一手拿着Dr. Pepper上台，那也没关系，洛伊斯，做得太棒了。
By this point, I was finding my own way home from rehearsal. Lois couldn't give me a ride if she was always rushing off to some party or restaurant with, what she referred to as, "the gang from Elsinore." I would wave them off and wait in the parking lot for one of my parents to drive me home.
到这个时候，我都是自己想办法从排练场回家。如果洛伊斯忙着和她口中“艾尔西诺的帮派”去聚会或餐馆，她根本没法载我。我会跟他们挥手告别，在停车场等着父母来接我。
"The thing to remember," my mother said, "Is that 10 years from now, you could wake up underneath one of these people and have no idea you'd ever even seen them before. Time passes. You'll see. Enough liquor and people can forget anything. Don't let it get to you. If nothing else, it's taught you to skim the change while buying their drinks."
“你要记住的是，”我母亲说，“十年后，你可能会在这些人中的某个人身边醒来，却完全不记得自己见过他们。时光流逝，你会明白的。喝足够多的酒，人们可以忘记任何事。别让这影响到你。如果说还有什么收获，那就是你学会了买酒时偷偷扣下找零。”
I didn't appreciate her casual attitude. But the business with the change was insightful. My mother had the vengeful part down. It was the craft of acting I thought she knew nothing about.
我不认同她那种漫不经心的态度。但关于找零钱的事倒很有洞察力。我母亲深谙复仇之道，至于演戏的门道，我觉得她一窍不通。
We were in dress rehearsal when the director approached Lois in regards to a production he had planned for the fall. This was to be a musical based on the lives of roving gypsies, and he had her in mind for the role of a lusty bandit. Lois couldn't sing. Everybody knew that. Neither could she act or play the tambourine. I watched the man kneel down in the grass and literally beg her to accept the part.
我们在彩排时，导演找到了洛伊斯，谈及他秋季计划的一部作品。那是一部关于流浪吉普赛人生活的音乐剧，他想让她出演一个好色的女强盗。洛伊斯根本不会唱歌，人尽皆知。她也不会演戏或弹奏铃鼓。我看着那个人跪在草地上，简直是在求她接下这个角色。
When I expressed an interest, he suggested I might enjoy working behind the scenes in some backstage capacity. He meant for me to hang lights or lug scenery, to turn into one of those guys with low-riding pants and a belt burdened with wrenches and thick roles of gaffer's tape. Anyone thinking I might be trusted with electrical wiring had to be a complete idiot. And that's what this man was.
当我表示出兴趣时，他建议我可以去幕后做些后勤工作。他的意思是让我去挂灯或搬布景，变成那种裤子垮着、腰带上挂满扳手和厚胶带卷的人。任何认为我可以胜任电工工作的人，绝对是个彻头彻尾的白痴。而这个人就是那样。
I looked at him clearly then, noticing how his tights made a mockery of his slack calves and dumpy little basket. If he was such a big, stinking deal, what was he doing in Raleigh, North Carolina? His blow-dried hair, the Cuban-heeled shoes and rainbow-striped suspenders-- it was all a sham. Why wear tights with suspenders when their only redeeming feature was that they promised to stay up on their own?
我那时看清了他，注意到他的紧身裤是如何衬托出他那松垮的小腿和臃肿的裆部的。如果他真有那么了不起，为什么会待在北卡罗来纳州的罗利？他那吹出的发型、古巴跟的鞋子和彩虹条纹的背带——这一切都是骗局。既然背带的唯一优点就是承诺能自己稳住裤子，又何必还要穿紧身裤加背带呢？
And acting? The man performed as though everyone around him sported a shrimp-sized hearing aid clamped to their ear. He shouted his lines, grinning like a jack-o-lantern and flailing his hands as if he were fighting off gnats. His was a form of acting that never fails to embarrass me. It's the same feeling I get when watching someone hawk a vegetable slicer or deliver a singing telegram. You know it's supposed to sound convincing. But you can't get beyond the sad fact that this person actually thinks he's bringing some joy into your life. Somewhere he's got a mother sifting through a shoe box of mimeographed playbills, pouring herself another drink and wondering when her son is going to come to his senses and swallow some drain cleaner.
还有表演？这家伙演戏就好像周围每个人耳朵上都塞了个虾米大小的助听器一样。他大声喊着台词，咧着嘴笑得像个杰克南瓜灯，双手乱舞，好像在驱赶蚊子。他的表演风格永远让我感到尴尬。就像我看到有人在推销蔬菜切片机或表演送歌电报时那种感觉一样。你知道它是为了显得有感染力，但你无法忽略一个可悲的事实：这个人真的认为他在给你的生活带来快乐。在某个地方，他的母亲正翻着装满影印剧目单的鞋盒，给自己又倒了一杯酒，想着她的儿子什么时候才能清醒过来，去喝口通渠剂了结此生。
I saw Hamlet for the man he was and, in the process, saw myself as a sort of sad sack Yorick who would blindly follow along behind him.
我把哈姆雷特看作他本来的样子，在这个过程中，我也把自己看作是一个盲目追随在他身后的悲惨约里克。
My parents attended the opening night performance. Following my, "Aye, my Lord," I laid on the grass as Lois poured a false vile of poison into my ear. As I lay dying, I opened my eyes enough to see my father sleeping, my mother stretched out beside him fighting off the moths who, along with a few dozen humans, had been attracted by the bright light.
我的父母参加了首演之夜。在我说完“是的，我的大人”之后，我躺在草地上，路易斯把一瓶假毒药倒进我的耳朵。当我躺着等死时，我睁开眼睛，看到父亲在睡觉，母亲躺在他身边，驱赶着那些和几十个人一起被明亮的灯光吸引来的飞蛾。
There was a cast party afterwards, but I didn't go. I changed my clothes in the dressing room where the actors stood congratulating one another. Horatio asked me to run to the store for some cigarettes and I pocketed his money, promising to return with lightning speed.
演出结束后有一个演职员聚会，但我没去。我在更衣室里换了衣服，演员们站在那里互相祝贺。霍拉肖让我去商店买些香烟，我把他的钱揣进兜里，答应会以闪电般的速度回来。
"You were the best in the whole show," my mother said, stopping for frozen pizza on her way home. "I mean it. You walked onto that stage and all eyes went right for you." It occurred to me then that my mother was a better actor than I could ever hope to be. Acting is different than posing or pretending. When done well, it bears a striking resemblance to lying. I didn't envy my mother's skill. Neither did I contradict her. That's how convincing she was. It seemed best, sitting beside her with a frozen pizza thawing on my lap, to simply sit back and learn.
“你是整场演出中最棒的，”母亲在回家的路上停下来买冷冻披萨时说。“我是认真的。你一走上舞台，所有人的目光就都集中在你身上。”我当时突然想到，我的母亲是一位比我所能希望的更好的演员。演戏不同于摆姿势或假装。当演得好时，它与撒谎有着惊人的相似之处。我不嫉妒母亲的技巧，也没有反驳她。她就是这么有说服力。坐在她身边，膝盖上放着一个正在解冻的冷冻披萨，最好的办法似乎就是安坐一旁，好好学习。
David Sedaris lives in New York City. He's the author of Barrel Fever . "Drama Bug" is from an upcoming book.
大卫·塞达里斯住在纽约市。他是《桶中热》一书的作者。“戏剧虫”选自他即将出版的一本书。
[MUSIC- "THE MAN WHO MAKES YOU LAUGH" BY ANTHONY NEWLEY]
[音乐- 安东尼·纽利演唱的《那个让你发笑的人》]
I know this song is just getting better and better. But we don't have time to play the whole thing, and we have to spin head towards the end so you can hear this. This is just too good. Hold on. Here we go. Again just spinning ahead on our little tape machine so you can hear the end of this. Here we go.
我知道这首歌越来越好听了。但我们没时间播放完整版了，我们必须快进到结尾，这样你们才能听到这段。这简直太棒了。等等。开始吧。再次在我们的录音机上快进，这样你们就能听到结尾了。我们开始吧。
[MUSIC- "THE MAN WHO MAKES YOU LAUGH" BY ANTHONY NEWLEY]
[音乐- 安东尼·纽利演唱的《那个让你发笑的人》]
The song stylings of Mr. Anthony Newley here on This American Life . Act Three, "From the Audience Seats." OK, so you mean to go to the theater. That was so Baltimore, the way I just said that. OK, so you know you want to go to the movies. So you mean to go to the theater-- I'm from Baltimore so the accent creeps out sometimes-- so you mean to go to the theater. But it's so much trouble. And it's so much time. And tickets are expensive, and you have to pay the sitter, and there's parking, and yeah, yeah, yeah.
安东尼·纽利先生的歌曲风格，就在《美国生活》节目中。第三幕，“观众席”。好吧，你是说你要去剧院。我刚才那样说太有巴尔的摩味儿了。好吧，你知道你想去看电影。所以你是说你要去剧院——我来自巴尔的摩，所以口音有时会流露出来——所以你是说你要去剧院。但这太麻烦了。而且太花时间了。票很贵，你还得付钱给保姆，还得停车，哎呀，没完没了。
Mark O'Brien faces obstacles even more harsh than this to attend the theater. Because he had polio when he was a kid, he's in an iron lung. He can come out of the iron lung for a limited amount of time, though, and for a while-- as unlikely as this sounds-- he would use that time to go to plays. We offer this little piece of writing as an extreme example of what some people will go through, as audience, when they get the drama bug.
马克·奥布莱恩为了去剧院，面临着比这更严峻的障碍。因为他小时候患过小儿麻痹症，他必须待在铁肺里。不过，他可以在有限的时间内离开铁肺，有一段时间——尽管听起来不太可能——他会利用这段时间去看戏。我们提供这篇短文，作为一个极端的例子，说明当有些人迷上戏剧时，他们会经历什么。
The first time I attended a performance of the Berkeley Shakespeare Festival, they did Hamlet in the round. It began when a man pushed a wheelbarrow on stage, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] through a trap door that trundled down a ramp three feet from me. The guards ran onstage dressed in Green Beret uniforms. I was hooked.
我第一次参加伯克利莎士比亚戏剧节的演出时，他们表演的是环形剧场版的《哈姆雷特》。演出开始时，一个人推着独轮车上台，穿过一个活板门，在离我三英尺远的地方顺着坡道滚下来。警卫穿着绿色贝雷帽的制服跑上台。我被深深吸引住了。
After that, I went to every performance I could. The festival allowed a friend in for free. So every summer, I rented vans equipped with wheelchair lifts to take us to the park. The season's tickets cost more than $100, expensive for someone living on SSI. But as a friend told me, culture is what we live for, the reason we put up with bills, smog, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
那之后，我尽可能去观看每一场演出。戏剧节允许朋友免费入场。所以每年夏天，我都租用配备轮椅升降机的货车带我们去公园。季票价格超过100美元，对于靠社会安全补助金生活的人来说很贵。但正如一位朋友告诉我的，文化是我们活着的意义，是我们忍受账单、烟雾和[听不清]的原因。
The stage, surrounded by tall trees, faced a natural amphitheatre. I sat right next to the elevated stage [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. One of the light stands. One year, I bought two tickets for each performance. During a night performance of Coriolanus , the actor, the lead, dressed like a 20th century admiral, tore off his epaulets and hurled them offstage, nearly hitting me. The following week, the actor approached me before showtime.
舞台四周环绕着高大的树木，面对着一个天然的露天剧场。我就坐在高台旁边[听不清]。其中一个灯架旁。有一年，我为每一场演出都买了票。在《科利奥兰纳斯》的夜场演出中，那位主演，打扮得像20世纪的海军上将，扯下他的肩章并将其扔下台，差点砸到我。接下来的一周，那位演员在开演前找到我。
"I'm surprised you're back," he said, "I thought I might've killed you with those epaulets." I was so excited to meet him that I forgot to ask for his autograph.
“我很惊讶你又来了，”他说，“我以为我可能会用那些肩章砸死你。”我太兴奋能见到他，以至于忘了要他的签名。
Every performance was exciting because it was live and things might go wrong. Things seldom went wrong, but still there was always that chance. You [UNINTELLIGIBLE] that advantage from the deadly perfect land of movies and television.
每一场演出都令人兴奋，因为它是现场直播，可能会出岔子。虽然很少出岔子，但总是有那种可能。你从电影和电视那种死气沉沉、完美无缺的土地上获得了那种优势。
I love seeing the same actor take on different roles. One actor, who imitated Johnny Carson, who played the clown, Touchstone, for As You Like It -- the following week he was Richard II, the tyrannical, blustering king who becomes more eloquent, more human, after he's overthrown and imprisoned.
我喜欢看到同一位演员扮演不同的角色。有一位演员，他模仿约翰尼·卡森，在《皆大欢喜》中扮演小丑试金石——接下来的一周，他成了理查二世，那个暴虐、虚张声势的国王，在被推翻并入狱后，变得更加雄辩、更加人性化。
After many years in the park, the Berkeley Shakespeare Festival moved to a new amphitheatre in the suburbs. The stage area is half a mile from the entrance. When we reached our seats, I saw there wasn't a speck of shade. At 4:00 in the afternoon, it was well over 80. We often suffer for the things we love. This could be as true of Shakespeare as anything else. As an English major accustomed to the five-word sentences and flat inflections of Californians, I found Shakespeare's heightened sense of language intoxicating. It's not just the thees and thous. It's the metaphors, the jokes, the rhythms of the poetry and the jostling, bubbling, prose. So I thought I would suffer gladly for these pleasures.
在公园里演了多年之后，伯克利莎士比亚戏剧节搬到了郊区的一个新露天剧场。舞台区距离入口有半英里远。当我们到达座位时，我看到一点阴凉都没有。下午4点，气温远超80度。我们经常为我们所爱的事物受苦。这对莎士比亚来说和其他任何事情一样真实。作为一个习惯了加州人五字句和单调语调的英语专业学生，我发现莎士比亚那高度发展的语言感令人陶醉。这不仅仅是那些“你”和“你的”古语。还有隐喻、笑话、诗歌的节奏以及那种推搡、活跃的散文。所以我认为我很乐意为这些乐趣而受苦。
I stayed in that blast furnace of language too long. The heat made me so weak that I couldn't drink any water. I became ill and had to be hospitalized. In the hospital, I clapped [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I turned blue whenever the iron lung was off for more than three minutes. My doctor thought I would die. It took me six weeks to become well enough to leave the hospital. I told people I nearly became the first person to die from Shakespeare. It could be worse. Abraham Lincoln died from a lousy comedy.
我在那座语言的熔炉里待得太久了。高温让我虚弱到无法喝水。我病倒了，不得不住院治疗。在医院里，我拍手[听不清]。每当铁肺关掉超过三分钟，我就脸色发青。我的医生以为我快死了。我花了六周时间才恢复到足以出院的程度。我告诉人们，我差点成为第一个死于莎士比亚作品的人。这还算好的，亚伯拉罕·林肯死于一场糟糕的喜剧。
Mike O'Brien lives in Berkeley, California. He's a writer and poet, author of a book of poems called Breathing . His email address, Marko-- that's M-A-R-K-O-- @well.com.
迈克·奥布莱恩住在加州伯克利。他是一位作家和诗人，著有一本名为《呼吸》的诗集。他的电子邮箱地址是 Marko--也就是 M-A-R-K-O--@well.com。
I noticed my mother's face assume an expression she reserved for unspeakable horror. I had seen this look only twice before. Once when she was caught in the path of a charging, rabid pig and once again when I told her I wanted a peach-colored velveteen blazer with matching slacks.
我注意到母亲的脸上露出了一种她留给无法言说的恐怖的表情。这种表情我之前只见过两次。一次是她差点撞上一头冲过来的疯猪时，另一次是我告诉她我想要一件桃红色的天鹅绒西装外套和配套的休闲裤时。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。